my name is chris white so I currently
work at Capital One and just to warn you
my background is in math so there will
be will be some math on some of these
slides and also I'm from UT Austin I see
there's a longhorn guy in the back so to
all right all right so in this talk I
kind of want to get into logistic
regression and what's going on under the
hood and why I think it's important for
you to think about these sorts of things
I'm not entirely sure what the
background if everybody is so we're
going to kind of do a quick quick
refresher on what logistic regression is
and maybe what it's used for a little
bit so logistic regression has a
generative model underneath it so given
the parameters and given your input data
we're modeling an output which is
basically a coin flip so I'm thinking
only of the binomial case here and the
probability of seeing a heads or a one
in this case is given by this kind of
complicated or not so complicated
sigmoid function which looks like this
and so we take parameters multiplying
with our inputs feed them through this
function and then we get something
that's between 0 and 1 okay and with
this generative model we can do a little
bit of math and the reason it's set up
this way is this implies that the log
odds of the probability single one verse
zero is actually linear in the inputs
right so this is a linear model and
that's kind of a big deal because it
makes everything easy to interpret it
also makes some of the numerical stuff a
little bit easier so what are these beta
coefficients so remember these are the
things that we're after we've seen X and
we've seen why maybe and so if beta is
to then if we get a unit increase in an
input X that implies that the law God's
double right so sorry I also equal which
you know it's kind of important here but
uh the main thing here we've got this
set up we've given been given some data
and we want to know how do we find the
best values of beta that fit the data
that we saw in this setup because of its
interpretability because of a few other
things that we're going to talk about I
mean it's kind of used all over the
place for a ton of different sorts of
problems so
classification problems survival
analysis you can model say the
probability of say a credit card
charging off next month given that it
survived up to this point and then
because that's a probability you can do
some further maths of that and get get
more information so a typical answer for
how we might find the best value of beta
so that's kind of a subjective question
what does it mean to be best like how
does it fit the data best maximum
likelihood estimation so this is kind of
historical classical thing you just
write down the likelihood function which
is the probability of seeing the data
that you saw given your current value of
beta under an assumption of Independence
on everything that you saw you just get
this big product it's kind of a somewhat
messy looking thing so this this Sigma
here is the sigmoid function that we
talked about before so these details not
going to be super important but the good
thing in this particular case and
foremost generalized linear models this
function is concave so it's in general
going to have a unique Maximizer so
that's good we can hopefully find that
the fact that it's a maximum likelihood
estimator means that we can do classical
stats so basically we can do classical
stats and some other situations as well
but we need to know the asymptotic
distribution of our estimators and when
you have a maximum likelihood estimator
you know a lot more information about it
and one thing that I want to kind of
call out right here is that if you kind
of look at this for a second the sigma
beta times X are your predicted
probabilities and the wise or your
observed outcomes so they're zeros or
ones and so this is only really a
function of the predicted probabilities
and the observed probabilities or you
can at least write it in that way okay
so what have we done we just write down
a generative model for a binary outcome
we came up with a way of choosing the
best coefficients to fit the data that
we saw and now we're done right we have
an optimization problem we throw it into
some sort of a solver or s Kaline
logistic or something like that and we
move on with our life but the main thing
that I think I want to stress here
that just uncritically throwing your
data into something like this could
result in a bad model or maybe a little
less extreme thing to say is if you
think a little bit more about it you can
get a much better model out so what are
some of the decisions that you have to
confront here when you're choosing say
maybe just which solver to use you can
choose SK learn you could choose stats
models you might want to cut up your own
it's not super complicated what
decisions you have to make to influence
that so inference first prediction if
you're interested in inference then your
coefficients are incredibly important
right you want to compute P values maybe
you want to infer something about the
effect of your inputs on your output but
if you're only interested in prediction
then you might not care so much about
which sign your coefficients are taking
all you want is the actual predicted
value right and the predictions might
not change after a while even if you do
small changes to your coefficient so
I'll show you an example in a little bit
where that's the case I'm so like in the
presence of multicollinearity for
example if you do a linear
transformation of your inputs your
predictions don't change at all but the
interpretation of your model is entirely
different okay desired input so what
sort of data have you been given was it
may be categorical how did these solvers
handle categorical data missing values
another important thing what sort of
output are you looking for do you want p
values and if maybe the solver that you
put it into doesn't give you p values
can you compute them and does it make
sense to do so what about edge cases so
quasi separable data is data for which
the model is actually a really good
model so you can perfectly split your
outcome based on the inputs and in that
case the log likelihood is not does not
have a unique Maximizer so what happens
in that case and then maybe you want to
do some sort of regularization maybe you
want to build a Beijing model is that
allowed in the tool that you're choosing
so kind of throughout the rest of the
talk we're going to go through some of
these bullet points and we're going to
focus on stats models scikit-learn
and kind of randomly SAS so a lot of
companies nowadays are kind of
considering this transition from closed
source to open source and I think a big
arc there is maybe SAS to something like
Python and can you trust say pythons
output compared to Sasha's output so I
want to talk a little bit about that
okay prediction verse inference so in
the case of inference your coefficient
sign and precision are very important
and so an example here might be you're
building a model that does something
predicts maybe like I said before the
probability that a customer charges off
next month and one of your variables is
the unemployment rate and you're going
to use this model to see what sorts of
charge off rates you can expect under
stress conditions so you're going to
feed in very extreme values for
unemployment rate but you might hold
everything else to some median value so
if the sign of that thing is wrong or
unintuitive in some way then you're
going to get a very bizarre outcome
right and so in this particular case
it's very important and this is actually
a chart from real Bureau data so this
happens a lot in highly multikill in
your situations where you may be your
tolerance setting is somewhat low so we
have here along the x axis is the
tolerance for these two solvers so sk1
and staff models and this is some bureau
variable to this model something like
100 hundred different variables and
you're trying to predict the probability
of a credit card charge off and you can
see that at lower tolerance settings the
optimizer for stats models for a psycho
learn actually have different signs and
then as you increase that tolerance then
they start to agree which is what they
should because there's going to be you
need Maximizer right but the catch is
unless you kind of knew that you needed
to play with this tolerance setting you
might have gotten a model that actually
does something really really bad it has
the wrong sign on a really important
variable and then when you stress that
variable you get something crazy
happening
so this is a little bit just a repeat of
what I was just talking about so
multicollinearity has this kind of
statistical process t'kul effect but it
also could lead to some sort of
numerical problems right you might have
to invert a matrix it's got a lot of
correlated columns that might be hard to
do in some situation so how do you deal
with that and also it can affect
long-term model stability so if you have
variables that are correlated but maybe
not superb a bit if that correlation
changes over time then your coefficient
estimates are going to need to update to
reflect that change and you can test for
multicollinearity with things like
condition numbers I have to be a little
careful with those they're kind of scale
dependent or variance inflation factors
you can get some kind of weird output
from those as well so just kind of need
to understand what it is that you're
looking for okay so this is a breakdown
so now we're going to kind of start to
dig into some of the details of the
things that I was are the packages that
I was mentioning so we have this
optimization problem how are we going to
solve it we have different algorithmic
choices here so SAS is pakka logistic
the default is this thing called
iterative iterative leary weighted least
squares I can never say that and it's
convergence criterion is this thing
called the relative gradient criterion
so you take the gradient of the log
likelihood and then you basically pair
it with the Hessian you get a number
when that number is really small you say
it's converged and the idea there is
that the gradient is close to zero in
that case the gradient zero for a
concave function then you're at the
optimizer on scikit-learn does something
very different so it does coordinate is
sent and it's using the lib linear C
library and if convergence is based on
the log likelihood and I'll mention why
that's kind of an important distinction
stats models logit uses newton's method
which actually is equivalent to
iteratively roided least squares but has
some subtle numerical differences and
also yeah we'll talk a little bit more
about that and it's convergence is so
I'm calling it the L infinity
convergence so it's looking at the
absolute value of all coefficient
changes so if anyone co efficient
it moves by more than 10 to the negative
8 then it's not converged yet so it's
looking for coefficient precision and if
you're familiar with stats models you
know that it has a lot of inferential
stats it's kind of an inferential type
of type of package res SK learn it's a
little more on the machine learning side
you just want to get good predictions
out and speed also write these tolerance
settings are very different the loser de
tolerance the faster your algorithm is
going to be and then stats models gom
actually calls a different algorithm and
it is significantly slower than loggia
so something to be aware of and the
convergence criterion is a lot different
so it's the deviance which is basically
a lot of looking at changes in the log
likelihood yeah so the tolerance is just
going to be some number so some small
number and you're going to be looking at
something changing and when that thing
is changing by less than that number
you're going to say the algorithms
converged so in these cases are looking
at say gradient size changes in the log
likelihood or changes in the coefficient
values yeah yeah
and so I pointed out earlier the
log-likelihood is a function that
predicted probabilities and the observed
outcomes and so convergence criteria
based on log likelihood convergence are
emphasizing prediction stability and
we're going to tend to converge faster
yes
okay so let's kind of take a look at
what can happen under slightly different
implementations so like I said before it
really related least squares equivalent
to Newton so they should be to give you
the exact same behavior that's not
actually true so I've got this notebook
that we're going to look at really
quickly and I'm not gonna to run it
necessarily but I kind of want to scroll
through a few things I think are
important this is on my github by the
way if you want to play around with it
yeah that sounds right direction okay
good okay cool so you can play around
this you can change the convergence
tolerance and we'll see what algorithms
you have in just a second allow for LT
regularization here so you can see what
the effect of that is on your speed and
your your outcomes maximum number of
iterations you can pick some covariance
between two of your variables number of
observations how much noise you want and
also I kind of want to do a shout out to
stats models formulas um they're based
on our style formulas and you can kind
of feed in various transformations so in
this case I have the exponential of a
variable I don't actually have to create
that come up with a name which sounds
like that's not a big deal but when you
have really big models and you're
testing lots of transformations and
someone else has to look over that they
might not know what any of these
transformations are how they like what
variables they they used and so create
some data so this is what it looks like
so if you don't like stats models it's
actually calling this package called
patsy which creates these data frames
for you based on formulas so you can
just use that that's what I do here so
this D matrices function and this is the
data frame that we get out and so this
is just a little so here's some math
stuff that I just kind of want to
mention but ok let's just look at this
though so right here I just have a very
standard Newton step so Newton's step is
just I need to compute the Hessian I
need to invert it multiply it by the
gradient and then that's going to be my
step update so right
right here so how you go about computing
this step term is actually kind of
important so in this case so this is the
line right oops sorry this is the line
right here so i use numbas least squares
so this is actually instead of inverting
the matrix I'm just trying to solve the
equation Hessian vector equals gradient
I'm not actually computing the full
inverse of this matrix so hopefully this
will be faster and then in another step
I have this ultimate Newton step where I
actually compute the full inverse and
then do a multiplication they both
should give me the same answer but and
then ok I'd this convergence set up so
this is looking at beta is changing is
looking at log-likelihood changes and
then I run it on the exact same data and
so the only thing that I want to point
out you can look at the details later so
this is standard Newton with coefficient
convergence we get 11 iterations and
then we get somewhere that's not very
right because there's a lot of
correlation here then we do standard
doing with log likelihood and only do 9
iterations you can make this much more
drastic with like a hundred verse 50 if
you play around with it enough and then
we do alternate newton step with log
likelihood convergence we get the exact
same thing as before so no change but
then we do alternate newton with
coefficient convergence and it just
breaks so drastically different output
on all of these different settings and
they seemed like really really minor
decisions and you can play around with
that later if you're interested ok so
just quick quick run through of just
some more superficial things that you
also need to think about when choosing
these things so how are you going to
handle missing values so stats models is
just going to fit the model on all the
complete observations and not tell you
anything so you need to be able to check
for that that's going to result in a bad
model if you're missing values are not
at random if they correlate somehow with
your outcome um how are categorical
inputs handled so with formula notation
you can just put a see around the
category
variable and will defy it for you for
stats MA sorry for scikit-learn and base
stats models you need to demo fire
categorical variables yourself so that's
another decision you have to make what
is your base category going to be and
then scoring convention so this is kind
of a tricky one so scikit-learn and base
that's models if you give it new data
they're going to score that data based
on variable location whereas if you use
a formula API it's going to score by
name instead of location and I think so
this if you permit your columns anyway
you're going to get weird results output
so this most most packages will have
most of this necessary outputs at
various fit metrics etc but maybe p
value so this is something that I wanted
to mention so stats models and SAS will
give you p values because they're kind
of geared towards old school
statisticians with scikit-learn is not
going to maybe you want to compute those
p values yourself however so something
like scikit-learn it always uses
regularization you can't turn it off you
can turn the regulars a regularization
parameter to extreme values but it's
still there so if you compute P values
you're not I mean you're doing nothing
really right because if you have
regularization this thing's no longer a
maximum likelihood estimator your P
values don't actually aren't doing what
you think they should be doing they
don't mean what you think that should
mean speaking of p value is just kind of
a quick i don't have too much time to
dig into this i think that a quick rant
on p values so I don't have a have a
takeaway from this in just a second so
imagine you're sitting ordinary
least-squares you got one variable one
output you miss specify your model
though the true model of the mean of Y
is some nonlinear function f of X I
don't know something crazy sine X plus X
to the 51 or something so you do
ordinary least squares you can Pete your
mo Li you get this close form and in the
presence of more and more data this is
going to do exactly what it's supposed
to and it's going to converge to this
expectation so this expectation is with
respect to how you're sampling your
inputs and so if you kind of look at
this for a little bit you'll see that
this limit is going to be safe
positive if this expectation is positive
so your beta is going to converge to
something that's nonzero okay so what
does that mean well your p-value is
going to do its job and it's going to
converge to 0 because the data is not
the limit of the beta is not zero but
that's not really probably what you were
looking for you're going to infer
something about a linear effect when it
could be something totally insane it's
just the best fit line happens to have a
positive slope so the only thing that's
not to say don't use P values or
anything but in the presence of large
data sets you're just always going to be
picking up effects and so you can't rank
based on these things you can't really
make community decisions based on these
things okay so kind of switching gears
going back a little bit to some of the
options you have when you're when you're
fitting these things so maybe you've
heard of regularization maybe that's
something that you want to do so what is
regularization I've mentioned a few
times so you take your log likelihood
and instead of just maximizing it you
penalize it you add some turn to it um
this penalization is some measure of
complexity so you're penalizing
complexity here okay so what does that
mean and you pick this towel to decide
how much you want to penalize the
complexity so popular example l1 norm so
this is the sum of the absolute value of
the coefficients what does this do some
people call it lasso in case of ordinary
least squares so this is the this comes
about as the convex relaxation of the
best subset problem so you're looking
for the best sub set of coefficients
that explain your data and you want the
rest of them to just be set to zero so
maybe variable selection or something
like that so it typically results in
sparse coefficients except for
degenerate cases you also have l2
regularization on this results in
so-called Ridge coefficients and so this
word comes from if you have highly multi
co in your data and you plot the log
likelihood then you're going to see this
kind of like kink and where it gets
really flat and so that's a ridge and so
ridging is fixing the ridge so
historically though and this is
something I kind of wanted to point out
it was used for inversion
a poorly condition matrices so what
people would do is in that step where
you invert the Hessian you added
diagonal matrix to it and then invert
that so if the Hessian was like close to
being degenerate then adding this
diagonal matrix makes it full rank and
now you can invert it that seems like a
numerical decision not a big deal you're
just trying to fit this thing
numerically but it turns out that it's
actually a has statistical implication
so the second you do that your estimator
is not actually a maximum likelihood
estimator anymore so your interpretation
and inference you need to be really
careful with and you made a decision
that seemed like a numerical one but it
has statistical effects and so kind of
related this many of these options
actually subtly relate a result in
regularization so just kind of
mentioning SAS one more time has seen a
lot of people use this firth option um a
lot of times people use it for say small
samples or I think a class and balances
maybe but actually this is
regularization so you're adding a it's
equivalent to this thing called
jeffrey's prior on your coefficients but
you're adding this kind of complicated
penalization so log determinant of this
information matrix the point is that
it's regularization providing a ridge
factor value in stats models and this
the default here is actually nonzero and
it's equivalent to providing this towel
inverse so you're really doing LT
regularization and then SK learn you're
always doing regularization and you can
switch between l1 or l2 depending on on
what you're doing okay so i keep kind of
saying statistical effects of
regularization so kind of what's going
on behind the scenes here well anytime
you have a function where this integral
is finite so just basically any function
for the most part the earliest that you
could you would think of then your
regularization is actually arising as a
maximum a posteriori estimator for a
Beijing model where your prior is
proportional to this e to the negative
thing so okay if g here is the l2 norm
squared of your coefficient so the sum
was square root of the coefficients if
you put that in here then it's an
on distribution and so that arises from
putting a normal distribution on your
coefficients in the l1 case it's a
Laplace distribution so it's usually
something that you can you can call out
but so knowing this though then maybe
you're doing LT regularization you want
to shrink some of your coefficients and
there's some sort of correlation that
you expect for some reason that's
domain-specific you can go into this
prior and actually start to play with
what this prior is and it's still going
to be basically LT regularization but
it's going to be end up being some sort
of weighted one and it's going to be
more tailored to to your situation
you're going to be giving it more
information than just this generic Ltd
normalization and so hopefully I kind of
went through a lot of different things
here I think but the main takeaway that
I really wanted to I guess leave you
with is just that even if you don't
experience a lot of these edge cases
with tons of variables that are highly
correlated or quasi separable data or
anything understanding what's going
under the hood gives you a wealth of
information that hopefully you can use
to improve whatever it is that you're
doing and maybe get a better model out
at the end of the day so any any
questions yeah
why them
they
almost not a not 100 break its kind of
apples oranges so if you have a given
tolerance setting and then you look at a
change in the log-likelihood versus a
change in the coefficients this scale is
a little bit different so you're not
necessarily going to get the same
predictions in in practice you will but
it's not a guarantee
they
yeah I mean I guess the main thing that
I want to stress though is that the
tolerance setting itself if you fix that
and then do different convergence
criteria different algorithms then I
mean you they're just they're different
in terms of like how they're measuring
how close they are to the solution I
mean it depends on depends on the
application if I really do just want
speed and prediction than something like
log likely convergence is going to be
some times two times faster than
coefficient conversions but if I have to
explain you know every coefficient of a
model and I want to extrapolate then
coefficient convergence i think is going
to be more more beneficial yeah
gian convergence
because we're just using it as a linear
model again you're I think that so the
question was is there a theoretical
guarantee of convergence and it's a good
question it's a concave problem so you
think definitely but using Newton's
method there's not because you not you
don't have say like a gamma in front of
that Hessian that's controlling how far
you you move so you could do something
where you just alternate back and forth
so there's not actually a guarantee yeah
well I guess is you're saying there's no
guarantee for the bear claw you ready so
yeah but not strictly so not always
strictly so so you could I mean and
that's if you have linear dependencies
in your data then it's not going to be
strictly concave but in any sort of real
world case when you don't have perfect
correlation there's gonna be any gets
Cooper yes strictly concave yeah very
reliable our training methods within the
libraries that provide confidence
intervals for beta coefficient
so are you thinking of in the presence
or absence of regularization okay so in
the presence of regularization the
libraries as far as I know don't provide
anything but what you could do is
compute the posterior distribution so
it's a Beijing model so you have
actually a full probability distribution
for all your coefficients and then you
can compute a yet Beijing intervals for
that for that with regularization is
something you would have to do for just
if you have large data but you're doing
kind of classical non regular stuff
stats models gives you standard errors
and in confidence intervals if you want
to know yeah conserve sass as well yeah
other questions
just join image so what I was thinking
of there is I've seen a lot of people do
so PCA but then they remove the just
singular singular values when they do
the transformation so that's and then
that so that's their normalized data and
uh yeah in that sense they change the
scale of the condition number to
something yeah yeah but so okay so
another thing that you I guess another
case that it really if you have say a
matrix and then you throw in something
that's totally independent but you just
scale that column then you can just
start to scale up the condition number
arbitrarily and so i guess i've i've
heard people say like oh if your
condition number is greater than this
then you have multicollinearity and you
need to like normalize the columns in
some way to make sure there's not just
one like the large eigenvalue might be
headed in one direction independently of
everything else and you can just make it
arbitrarily large yeah that's what any
other questions all right thanks for
your time